this is our garden my father is
cultivating some stuff like tomatoes
pumpkins a lot of potatoes
and this is all polluted heavily
polluted
how does it make me feel
um being a neighbor of 3M Company I
don't like them being my neighbors but
they are I use stuff of gym which I
don't want to but it's just like that I
have no other option they are everywhere
my entire family
is highly effective
by that stupid chemical
you may not realize it but almost
everyone has some level of pfas in their
bloodstream because these products are
everywhere in our everyday environment
pfas is the umbrella term for thousands
of different kinds of chemicals they're
known as forever chemicals they are
man-made chemicals used in thousands of
different kinds of products they are
miraculous chemicals you can't find a
better coating for instance to make your
jacket waterproof they've made our lives
convenient in many ways from the foods
you eat to the sofa you sit on
to the rain jacket you put on when you
go outside
but the problem is they don't degrade in
the environment and they're almost
impossible to get rid of they accumulate
in soil Rivers drinking water and in the
bloodstream of people who are exposed to
them and now pfos chemicals are
associated with a range of health
problems hormone and immune disorders
thyroid malfunctions but as well high
cholesterol and diabetes kidney problems
and even a diminished vaccine efficacy
3M maintains that these chemicals are
not harmful to human health and the
levels detected in the environment but
of course that really depends on where
you're talking about in some areas
particularly around the factories that
they have the levels detected in the
environment are incredibly High
3M is a global Corporation a
conglomerate that makes a wide range of
products everything from its Flagship
product Scotchgard to protect Fabric and
your sofa it makes Post-it notes
it makes n95 masks but it also makes
everyday products that are not branded
3M has billions in sales and factories
in different parts of the world
3m's Factory is located on the banks of
the river shelled in the city of Antwerp
it is part of Europe's biggest chemical
cluster
a highway separates that chemical
cluster from what is a Suburban farming
community
3M began operating in Belgium in the
1970s and started making pfas there in
1976.
now it stopped making pfos there in 2002
but in those intervening years it
contaminated the surrounding area
those people living
just behind the 3M Factory were exposed
to the pfos emissions from that plant
including from the air and the soil and
the water and it's had a really
devastating impact both on the people
who live and work there
I live let's say
um
500 meters away from
the chemical plant of the 3M Company
I live here with my family three
children my husband
my parents just across the door my
brother across the street and
that's me so we live here for
[Music]
um five generations long
and they tell me just like two years ago
hmm maybe it's better that your children
don't play outsides and that you clean
your house two times a week in a really
proper way because we know that we
produce a chemical and it's in your
house it's in your garden and it's not
good for your children
I don't want to expose my children to
those chemicals so everybody was like
move move and I was like why I already
exposed them in a huge amounts just by
holding I just by being pregnant just by
by feeding them I expose them as a mom
so I breastfeed my my daughter for at
least a year uh six months to a year
I was happy
it was fine everything was fine and
suddenly she becomes 40 years old and
not everything was fine any any longer
she has a problem
according to
outside world
she's slightly disabled why because she
had a shortness of oxygen in her in her
brain and some things are not working
that well anymore maybe the problem is
caused by that Chemical Company maybe
not
is she dying no
will she get cancer who knows I don't
know I don't know how bad it is you know
and nobody knows nobody even dream they
say they don't know
but I give her a huge huge huge amount
of that kind of chemical because I
thought yeah it's good to breastfeed why
not it's easy nice easy it's nature you
know it's just like yeah what you're
supposed to do as a mom
I didn't do anything wrong
so we eliminate pfas through loss of
blood or in the urine but one of the
biggest ways of eliminating pfas is
through pregnancy and breastfeeding
which is incredibly worrisome that means
that children have some of the highest
exposures because mothers pass pfas from
their bloodstream onto their fetuses and
children are incredibly vulnerable to
contamination because their organs are
still developing their biochemistries
are still evolving
some scientists describe this to me as a
ticking Time Bomb for future Generations
this contamination might never have come
to light if not for a plan to build a
multi-billion Euro tunnel and Highway
project that was due to pop out right
next to 3m's factory in Antwerp the plan
required the digging up of tons of soil
and River silts
and being moved to different parts of
Belgium
the decision to move all this soil to
other parts of
Flanders let activists start
scrutinizing what what's in the soil
and uh two activists came across some
documents that they've requested from
the state highway company and from
Flemish regulators and discovered that
the soil being dug up near the 3M
Factory was heavily contaminated with
pfos
in the middle of this uh environmental
report on the sanitation report for 3M I
find what's pretty much a photocopy of a
groundwater measurements from 2000s
and my first reflex is like oh there's a
problem with the decimal uh comma or
point you know I was thinking oh you
know they they misplaced it so it's like
a thousand times too much or it must be
but it wasn't it was like you know 250
000 uh micrograms per liter I think just
so staggeringly high uh I'd never seen
numbers like that even you know in these
International reports and that's you
know that was loose in the groundwater
underneath three animals
if we go by the current data and the
knowledge from the European food safety
administration they get to like a norm
around four nanograms per liter for
drinking water
now what is what we saw there was
something that was in the order of a
couple of 100 million times that
that's what we're talking about
now this uh caused a chain of events
that caused a huge political scandal
what came out was that the state-owned
highway company had done a secret deal
with 3m that would enable them to
deposit the most contaminated and
polluted soil onto 3m's Factory site to
build what they called a security wall
on a site that previously didn't need
any kind of security wall and the catch
was that they could move contaminated
soil as long as it served a function
and if you look at the the permit for it
there's no indication that's actually
storage for for polluted soil it's just
not in there
[Music]
so this roundabout actually contains
really heavily polluted FIFA soil so
technically it's an illegal waste dump
but because it's already in here
uh they're basically saying oh we're not
you know it's a done deal We're Not
Gonna
bother uh you know getting it out if
it's even possible
so this is a this is a whole problem you
know in this this area with the with the
Tunnel construction company is there
trying to create situations where it's
impossible to rectify it
was a public outcry activist then
crowdfunded to start testing the
bloodstream of certain residents who
live near the factory for pfos and when
those results came out
uh in August 2021
it caused Mayhem because many of those
people that they tested and just at
random had incredibly high levels of
pfos in their bloodstream in one case
a woman in her 60s had levels that were
comparable to Industrial Wastewater
so 3M has been churning out varieties of
pfas chemicals since the 1950s
but it began doing studies in the 70s
that made them realize that these
chemicals were highly toxic
including two studies in the late 1970s
on monkeys which uh were disclosed as
part of a lawsuit in 2018 it was being
sued for harming the health of residents
of Minnesota who lived near 3m's
headquarters
[Music]
they found high levels of pfas in
drinking water particularly those people
who had Wells on their property and they
noted higher rates of cancer and
Leukemia in residents that lived nearby
in 2018 3M agreed to settle a lawsuit
brought by the state of Minnesota by
paying 850 million dollars without
admitting any wrongdoing in 2003m
announced it would stop producing longer
chain pfas as a precautionary measurer
saying the chemicals were safe but they
announced they would be replacing them
with shorter chain equivalents that they
said were safer
those are now believed to be potentially
equally dangerous to the environment and
to human health because they're highly
mobile and they spread in the
environment more easily
they tried to project a uh you know
[Music]
side or you know corporate responsible
uh few you know
but in the end they've known since the
80s how toxic this this product was
[Music]
I think it's really disappointing that
3M reached this agreement to pay 580
million to the Flemish government but so
many of the residents are left in limbo
worried about their health worried about
their kids worried about their house
prices worried about their surrounding
environment and very little has been
done
now they say don't play outside don't
eat your vegetables I'm like it's your
child how I can tell my child like
please don't walk with your bare feet
don't touch the soil because it's
polluted
it's impossible and now I have to say
don't touch up Apple Don't touch don't
do it's poison
and then they're like hmm is it a fairy
no it's not a fairy it's real life we
cannot eat those apples it's poison
don't touch
out
[Music]